this is lucy james reading for writer
alessandro barbosa
thanks to the success of netflix's drive
to survive the further surrounding
formula one the world's premier racing
category has rarely been stronger the
sport has seen a huge influx of new fans
enjoying not only some of the best
racing the sport has seen in over a
decade but also injecting a lot more
meaning into the relationships between
its teams and drivers off the track
right let's get the car up to
temperature on this lap please in f1
2022 the latest entry in the franchise
developed by custodians codemasters a
delicate balance of catering to this new
audience while also offering
enhancements to returning simulation
racing fans is evident and based on some
limited time i've had with the game it
seems to strike it quite well in the
preview version of f1 2022 i had access
to all 10 teams and 20 cars on the grid
along with 5 tracks to race on imola
silverstone in great britain the red
bull ring in austria circuit of the
americas in texas and the latest
addition to the f1 calendar the miami
international autodrome all five were
available for racing in both grand prix
and time trial events with the grand
prix event featuring practice sessions
qualifying and even sprint races or none
if you decide to edit the race weekend
format directly this is just a sliver of
what codemasters will be offering when
the game launches in july in addition
career mode and my team campaigns will
return and feature the formula 2
championship again although a narrative
focused mode akin to breaking point last
year is not returning race weekends will
also be expanded with more of the fun
events that take place in real life like
hot laps with drivers and celebrities as
well as drift autocross and average
speed zone challenges that can be
tackled with both a variety of supercars
including f1's own safety cars for the
first time there's a lot planned for
this entry that expands upon the
familiar format of a formula one weekend
but still ties itself closely to the
sport not letting it tread too far into
territory occupied by the likes of forza
motorsport or gran turismo but letting
the overlap of players enjoy some
variety regardless what the preview did
offer despite its limited content was
the chance to see how f1 2022 has
adapted into an f1 season that is
grappling with massive changes itself
this year f1 introduced long overdue
changes to almost all its regulations
redefining how teams can spend money how
they can develop their cars and most
importantly how those cars can be
designed it has led to incredibly
different chassis designs that while not
wider and only slightly longer allow for
drastically closer racing as the sport
tries to spice up on track action during
each race anyone who has watched this
season thus far will likely tell you
that it has worked mostly and it's
evident that those changes are reflected
accurately in f1 2022 when set to mirror
real world performance here cars will
behave according to their relative
performance in real life as opposed to
all cars being the same you can quickly
see how the field bunches up together
for a lot longer especially when you're
turning up the lap count to force
mandatory pit stops it puts a much
greater emphasis on nailing each lap
than previous entries as the opportunity
for an opponent to pass you on the next
straight is always lingering it also
allows for more aggressive play on the
track with familiar corners now feeling
a little wider thanks to the new
dimensions of the cars given how
accurately these cars have mapped the
real-life circuits you might find
yourself with entirely new ways to
challenge opponents with how these new
cars behave which should satiate both
returning players and new ones alike if
this happens to be the first f1 title
you've played or at least the first
you've tried in a long time then many of
its systems might initially feel
overwhelming the numerous assists let
you turn f1 2022 from a dedicated sim
racer to something far more forgiving
and video game like with familiar
settings for traction control braking
assistance gearbox settings and more new
to f1 2022 is an adaptive ai difficulty
that will overrule the realistic nature
of the ai and transform races into more
closely contested affairs across the
field with three settings governing how
difficult the drivers are to race
against this setting is great for
newcomers or those looking for something
more traditional to racing games where
mechanics like rubber banding keep all
opponents close enough to feel like
either persistent threats or possible
hurdles to overcome it doesn't reflect
how f1 really works but it gives a
rather malleable racing game even more
room to adapt to new types of players
another new feature is the inclusion of
several broadcast modes for certain
parts of a race these remove you from
control and swing the camera in
positions you might recognize from a
live broadcast adding a cinematic feel
to each instance these are used during
formation laps the single lap drivers
take before the start of a race during
safety cars and when coming into the
pits the complexity of racing each of
these is entirely removed for you to
instead just enjoy the view which works
together with the game's new breezy
difficulty settings they can also be
turned off individually if you want to
participate in some and not others so it
comes down to how close to a real f1
race you want to get when tackling a
grand prix weekend
the counter to these new approaches to
crucial points in each race are more
nuanced gameplay mechanics if you want
to personally partake in them formation
laps now end with the ability to
position your car within your grid space
at different angles letting you define
which line you want to take from the
start to be more aggressive or defensive
once the lights go out
pit stops have also been slightly
tweaked with a new mechanic that ties
turning into your pit box to a timed
button press miss the timing on this and
your entire stop might take slightly
longer than usual losing you precious
seconds in a tightly contested race f1
2022's ai is also configured to make
these mistakes from time to time too in
order to preserve an element of
unpredictability to races but this can
also be neutralized in multiplayer games
to keep the playing field even
codemaster's approach to customizing f1
to a degree that makes it feel both
challenging but welcoming has been a
persistent aspect of many modern entries
in this series however f1 2022's changes
go beyond previous installments adapting
the game for potentially new audience
without compromising on the simulation
routes that the gameplay is built upon
with the series esport presence this
isn't surprising but it's still great to
see the series stay in step with where
both the sport and its viewership is
heading it gives f1 2022 a sense of
magic to it allowing you to feel the
thrill of pulling off a tight technical
lap that feels authentic to the f1
experience no matter what assists you're
using to get to that point there's a
balance achieved that still makes each
new best time feel well earned and not
one only afforded to you because you've
made everything that much easier to deal
with in an age where fans over formula
one might have been around for a handful
of decades or less than a few years it's
a smart approach to ensure everyone can
have fun with what has been one of the
best racing games each year consistently
and there's no indication yet that f1
2022 will be any different when it
launches in july
absolutely fantastic that is a brilliant
brilliant result well done
[Music]
you